staying in the game surviving with the
white king maybe magnus carson missed
that last move
by nakamura sliding the white king
across that wasn't obvious either this
one
both players coming up with surprises at
every turn not playing the most obvious
move every time
just trying to set traps for the
opponent and that now max 30 seconds for
magnus carlsen
yeah okay but the position is still
incredibly promising for hikaru and it's
all
because of that pawn that is two squares
from queening in the center
all hikaru needs to do is control the
queen
and the bishop and then the game will be
in the bag and he hasn't
one minute on his clock to do it magnus
reacting what's happening
i think he's realized that he made a
mistake earlier on um his last move was
pretty much forced i don't think he had
any other options so
it kind of been that last move that
magnus is annoyed about he must have
been annoyed because he suddenly
realizes
he had an opportunity earlier um
yeah the world champion we've seen his
brain works in such mysterious ways
maybe he's just realizing that he did
have some better moves and now he knows
he's in big big trouble